the discovery of the americas was a
pretty big deal
as you know christopher columbus made
his journey there in 1492 and he
returned early the next year
but upon his return what was the general
reaction to his discovery
how did europeans react to the discovery
of the new world well as many of you
will be aware columbus wasn't the first
european to see or set foot in the
americas
that title goes to lay for eriksen who
almost 500 years earlier had sailed to
north america
news of which had reached iceland and
the rest of the scandinavian world
shortly afterwards
his journey is preserved in sagas but
beyond that there is no known reaction
to this discovery
what is known is that by the 1300s most
people had completely forgotten about it
and many wondered if those lands were
even real
anyway in 1493 columbus returned to
europe and his letters concerning the
discovery were published soon afterwards
and they quickly spread throughout
europe and became extremely popular
reading
there was a lot of excitement especially
among merchants and rulers since a
direct route to asia had been confirmed
because at this point people didn't know
that columbus had discovered a new
continent they thought he'd simply
reached the indies
and thus made the spanish monarchy's
dreams come true like most spanish
dreams this one was brought to an end by
the portuguese who sent vasco de garma
to sail south and find a route around
africa
he succeeded and when he returned in
1499 the distance he travelled and the
stories he told meant that columbus
probably didn't discover asia
these new suspicions weren't confirmed
until americo vespucci returned from his
voyage in 1503
and upon his return he referred to the
lands that he visited as the new
world his findings were published and
within 40 years this new world had been
named after him
so how did europeans react to this new
world well to start this wasn't some
earth-shattering discovery for most
europeans
new lands had previously been discovered
in the azores and the canary islands and
the existence of the americas barely
affected them at all
since most europeans had much more
pressing issues and so disappointingly
the reaction of the average european was
largely muted and the same goes for the
church since the discovery of the new
world didn't contradict
any theology nor present any immediate
issues as for the rulers of europe they
did have varied responses
so the spanish were quick to accept that
this was indeed a brand new continent
with brand new peoples there was some
disappointment that this wasn't asia
since the primary motivation was trade
but instead
empire would be spain's consolation
prize and after this there were many
efforts to find a navigable waterway
through the continent to facilitate any
potential trade with asia
as for portugal they also soon came
around to this being a new continent and
whilst they had received a chunk of it
from the pope in 1494 their primary
focus was on that sweet sweet indian
ocean trade
whereas for the french the discovery of
the americas presented minor
opportunities for trade proselytising
and conquest but its rulers were
overwhelmingly focused on finding a
route to asia
the english were much much slower to
accept that the americas were indeed a
brand new landmass
the fact was until the late 16th century
the english didn't really care for the
new world and was much more concerned
about internal issues of religion and
whether or not to fight france that day
and so in the end for the overwhelming
majority of europeans the discovery of
the americas was of great interest but
ultimately one which had very little
impact on their lives
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly money maker
marvin cassell moe rob waterhouse james
castaneda jerry lamdin gustav swan aaron
the whites jordan longley marcus asner
charles the first
rasheed ali coppertone maggie paxkowski
lexi schwinn miss is it
matthew shipley robert wetzel spinning
three plates spencer lightfoot
corso wolf anthony beckett and winston k
wood